so we're talking about
um Valentine's Day Saint Valentine's Day
the the Hallmark card special
um yeah I guess we should start with
that right
because it is a Hallmark holiday
or so it's called
um
what's another Hallmark holidays
Hallmark holidays
I think I think Valentine's Day is one
of the biggest ones
for sure
um it's religious and origin obviously
St Valentine's
um I think if I'm not mistaken it was
tied into like a feast or a vessel or
something like that and there's some
like story that was infused into it
which turned into romance through the
biblical uh scriptures where
um you know the dude was in prison and
he fell in love with some Galder in that
uh period of time I can't remember all
the exact details you guys could look it
up but yeah it's been around for a few
years and I think that one of the things
that's happened is that marketers and
you know the corporate world has they're
always looking for some reason to run a
sale or sell you extra [__] that you
generally don't need right
Black Friday Cyber Monday turbo Tuesday
whatever thirsty Thursday like they just
you know those dates that like lead up
to you know Christmas sort of thing so
they can ramp up some sales
again I always date myself when I was a
kid we had boxing day that was it boxing
day was a big sale day now you've got
cyber days and block days and blue days
and brown days it's like holy [__] man
anyway
um so back onto the St Valentine's Day
thing it's it's a Hallmark holiday
I think culture sort of Beats it into
you you know it's like you know one of
those things where it's just now you
know elementary school days we used to
have these little cards they were like
business cards but a little bit larger
and they were Valentine's Day cards and
be like to and from and then you'd get a
Valentine's and
um you know the geeky kids didn't get a
lot of them and you know the cool kids
did obviously and sometimes you'd get
candy you know attached to it and you
know the girls would blush and the guys
would be like oh she likes me sort of
thing and um yeah that's that that's
like most kids introduction I think to
you know to Valentine's Day although
from what I hear some schools They Don't
Really
um
they don't brace it
anymore if that's the correct way to
sort of frame it they don't really
encourage the kids to exchange cards or
I'm I'm going to venture a guess here
and somebody can correct me in the live
chat or in the comments but it's
probably got something to do with not
letting children feel left out
because you know everybody gets a
participation trophy now
right they don't keep scoring certain
sporting uh games anymore it's just
everybody just kind of plays and runs
around and you know
maybe somebody will keep score maybe
somebody won't sort of thing but you
know there's there's older and older
kids getting participation trophies and
I think that that might be one of the
reasons why you know the school system
is trying to eliminate it
anyway
um so what do I do with uh Valentine's
Day not much really to be honest with
you
um
I think it all depends on who you're
chick is right because there's some
women that are like all about this it
has to be like a sh like this big
[__] charade it's like a show they
want to be able to you know go to work
and show their girlfriends that oh look
I got 24 long stem roses and your
boyfriend didn't send you anything her
boyfriend said you're only 12 or
something like that or mine or higher
quality than yours are Becky sort of
thing because women were very
competitive that way you know they they
got to have the bigger Diamond they
gotta have the clearer Diamond they got
the shinier Diamond they gotta have the
better princess cut or whatever right
that's another [__] you know
um
Hallmark bit is the whole engagement
ring spiel
let me spend a minute on that actually
since I'm talking about it
um
most of you guys don't know this but the
origin of the engagement ring of course
is tied into romance with Valentine's
Day so we can talk about it Valentine's
Day also happens to be one of those days
where a lot of a lot of dudes get down
on one knee and make the biggest mistake
of their life and invite crazy into it
but we'll save that for another day but
the whole um notion of uh engagements
and engagement rings and diamonds was
like it wasn't a big one like diamonds
weren't that valuable back in the day
when they sort of kicked this off but
it's like they had them and then they
made this big marketing project which
they sold to the public along the lines
of
well if you love her you should you know
you should invest in that in that
relationship and that love and buy her a
diamond and spend uh three months of
your salary to uh no sorry they didn't
start with three months I think it was
30 days of your salary
um to you know show her that you love
her so you know you spend one twelfth of
your annual income to give her this
shiny piece of polished dinosaur [__]
that was in the ground you know a few
years ago before they dug it out and
polish it up sort of thing because
that's all it is it's just it's just
compressed uh carbon
and then you know the marketing team ran
that for a while and they sold a lot of
diamonds you know telling guys you know
spend one month of your salary on a
piece of dinosaur [__] and give it to a
girl and tell her that you love her and
marry her and uh the marketing team must
have back in those days I think it was
in the 20s it's like Bob did you see how
well that [__] worked yeah bill that was
incredible they fell for it
let's do this next year instead of doing
30 days let's tell them three months and
see if they buy that [__] okay let's
give that a shot and then they did and
then that's how you've you know arrived
at the three-month thing today uh
although in some cases they even go
farther and they ask for more but
you know it's one of those Hallmark
things right
um diamonds by the way they don't have a
lot of value like you know if you give a
girl a ten thousand dollar diamond and
you know like the marriage or the
wedding's called off or something like
that and you get it back in some cases
you don't even get it back sometimes she
ends up keeping it for whatever reason
which is strange and bizarre but let's
say you get it back you you're very
lucky to sell it for what you bought it
for you usually get a few thousand
dollars less it's just not a great
investment uh but you know that's what
they convinced people to do it's the
same thing with Valentine's Day
chocolates flowers candy I was doing
some Googling on um on video so sorry on
YouTube and I was coming across all
these videos that were like you know
10 best Valentine's Day gifts to give
her
um anything from um what's his name
Alpha M he always has those listicles to
some you know random you know
17 year old thought probably given
advice to guys on what to buy girls for
Valentine's Day and it's all [__]
it's all it's all just random like you
know guys are trying to get with girls
and they think that they can you know
win their way into their heart by buying
them flowers and chocolates and and
Specialties and two of the matter is
if a woman really digs your Vibe it
doesn't matter like it really just
doesn't matter
um there's a story of the Skittles man
which I'm going to share in this
broadcast as well before we uh switch
over the Q a in a little bit and don't
worry you guys will be able to call and
ask questions tonight on any topic you
want but um yeah the notion of the
skittle man is is is very interesting
I'm going to pull up the Chateau
hearties uh blog and I'll read it to you
guys but essentially there's you know
there's two men there's obviously that
Alpha seed and there's a beta neat and
the alpha seed would give it you know
just basically ignore a girl and not
give her much attention give her a bag a
Skittle sort of thing and then there's
the other guy who bends over backwards
to give everything under the sun and you
know she doesn't really pay much
attention to him she wants the guy that
doesn't the Skittles man so I'll get
into reading that in a little bit but
again Hallmark holiday right
um it's impossible to get a reservation
for dinner
I tried to do it in my 20s I was that
dork I was that guy right a couple of
reservation oh no sorry but fully book
we have a reservation oh no we're so and
you're calling around trying to be like
the romantic guy to take all that
[__] it's it's really a like look
go do it you know feel good doing it if
it's what you really want to do if you
think that it's obligatory if it's uh
chivalrous and all that stuff blah blah
blah
look every day is Valentine's Day for my
check
she's got a good life she's well taken
care of she's got a good guy you know we
go on a rally and take care of things we
go on a vacation you know trip is
covered right it's like you know every
day should be Valentine's Day for a
check in my life is a way that I see it
so I'm not going to go out of my way and
send you know 72 000 flowers to her at
work and be one of those obnoxious dorks
with the balloons and it's like okay you
know I'm gonna mark my territory in here
because this is really what guys are
doing right they're trying to mark their
territory Like She's mine that's mine
over there and that's why I sent that
over to her I don't know if you guys
remember sunflowers I don't know what
they cost today but they're [__]
expensive okay
they die very quickly
you want to deal with flowers I got a
better idea for you next time you're
shopping at Costco
not on Valentine's Day just grab a nice
bouquet of flowers bring it home put in
a vase when your chick comes over don't
don't even say anything just just put it
there
just put it there she'll notice it
that's it doesn't cost you a vast
Fortune
you're doing it as you're going about
your day anyway it's not in some stupid
Hallmark holiday you know because you're
trying to knock our socks off and
impress or whatever it's like whatever
you know you just don't that's just my
take on it that's what I think I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out